congratulations yeah I hate to bury what
I think is the real headline you got
engaged
that's exciting I don't have my ring on
I yeah it's gettin sized it was too big
I didn't forget I was like you were
afraid we were gonna steal it
yeah that's the colleges for me yeah we
have a bad reputation on this show I
can't take a diamond onto that show so
what was your engagement like I mean
what's the gentleman the gentleman is
Nate for a second
Peppe and and and he he went to great
lengths yeah
the proposal didn't he planned for like
six months it was in the Dubai Desert
there was camels and Falcons and I mean
it was a bunch of animals involved well
that now is sounding like a wildlife
attack Rome it there were snakes there
was a Roaring River but I was a snapchat
a lot you guys should follow me I'm
really funny and I was nap chatting oh
my god in the desert and I was like oh
my god I'm on a camel and then I was
like drinking champagne in the desert
and then I see rose petals and I was
like I should probably stop snapchatting
this what's happening and yeah and then
you had to stop snapchatting so the
deeper flames of the rain no no I just
had started to dawn on me then why am i
snapchatting that something's happening
yeah if happening yeah so he went he's
making the rest of us look bad
Oh anyone you got engaged Jews plan have
the ring to Villa delivered by Falcon no
I just threw a dead Falcon hide away
[Laughter]
that's all I did ruined it for all of us
he raised the bar for men everywhere
yeah guys him already